to say that the 94th annual academy
awards ceremony was eventful would be
something of an understatement this
week's oscars should have been memorable
for a number of reasons ariana dubose
and troy kotzer's history making wins
for example or the ceremonies
unprecedented yet effective hosting
arrangement instead the ceremony will
forever be recalled as the night will
smith slapped chris rock on a live
broadcast and then cursed him out in
front of millions of people the attack
was in response to a gi jain joke rockin
made about jada pinkett smith's
close-cropped haircut a consequence of
the autoimmune disease alopecia smith
initially laughed at the joke but
pinkett smith was immediately and
visibly upset and within seconds smith
could be seen striding to the stage to
deliver his now infamous slap to the
shocked presenter while he was clearly
and visibly shaken by the incident rock
recovered quickly referring to the
ceremonies broadcast as the greatest
night in the history of television
before resuming the show unsurprisingly
this moment has been the talk of the
town ever since it occurred and has
elicited numerous wide-ranging reactions
across the media so a lot happened
tonight
key takeaways what did you guys think um
always keep your guard up following the
incident a number of celebrities and
casual viewers alike took to twitter to
share their thoughts understandably some
viewers immediately jumped to rock's
defense kathy griffin for instance
tweeted it's a very bad practice to walk
up on stage and physically assault a
comedian now we all have to worry about
who wants to be the next will smith in
comedy clubs and theaters meanwhile
podcast host ethan klein echoed griffin
sentiments writing i'm in awe the show
went on like nothing happened will smith
punched a comedian for doing his job
elsewhere one twitter user noted
violence against cultural commentators
whether journalists or comedians has a
dangerous trickle-down effect another
pointed out that smith's response to
rock's joke and explanation constituted
literal textbook abuser behavior
director rob reiner similarly tweeted
will smith owes chris rock a huge
apology there is no excuse for what he
did he's lucky chris is not filing
assault charges the excuses he made
tonight were bullsh
in other words it seems like rock has
quite a few prominent supporters backing
him right now that said while there were
many twitter users who didn't hesitate
to make their support for rock clear
some have spoken up in support of will
smith's smack in response to the
shocking oscars moment comedian and
actor tiffany haddish shared her
thoughts on will smith's decision to
slap chris rock with people magazine
saying when i saw a black man stand up
for his wife that meant so much to me on
twitter nicki minaj posted you just got
to witness in real time what happens in
a man's soul when he looks over to the
woman he loves and sees her holding back
tears from a little joke at her expense
this is what any and every real man
feels in that instant while y'all seeing
the joke he's seeing her pain plenty of
other twitter users also weighed in with
their thoughts about the incident for
their part one user tweeted when is the
last time you've seen a black woman
publicly defended in real time i rest my
case meanwhile another observed that
sometimes you gotta get your hands dirty
maybe one week we'll manage to extend
protect black women to more than one
black woman additionally one user
pointed out the hurtful nature of chris
rock's joke about jada pinkett smith's
writing jada has been very clear about
her insecurities of her hair loss chris
went low and personal as an attack will
had every responsibility to stand up for
his wife obviously these are only some
of the many reactions that have fled the
internet in the time that has passed
since the original oscars broadcast
indeed the debate over the incident has
filled practically every social and
conventional media platform
unfortunately it seems that the
conversation surrounding this moment may
last longer than the memory of the films
that were actually honored check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]